no wonder the schoolchildren in New York
are writing on the sidewalks Martians go
home the first honorary award tonight is
a Tory acknowledgement of a great
indebtedness to the Bell & Howell
organization for their pioneering and
basic achievement sin the advancement of
the industry without their candidate
contribution the movies of today would
still be the movies of yesterday mister
HW r mo she'd will except for the Bell &
Howell organization
on behalf of the Bella mile company I
sincerely thank you for this marvelous
award perhaps no one in America has made
such pungent comment on the manners of
his countrymen as the gentlemen we are
about to honor some of us think of him
is the Emily Post of bedlam his name
that the head of a short subject has
been a wicked little promise of
merriment for over thirty years if this
next oscar has a smile on his face it's
because he knows he is going to a Smith
named Pete
ladies and gentlemen it would take a
tunnel much more eloquent than mine
to express how I feel about this
particular Oscar and so to put it
rightly but most sincerely thank you
from the bottom of my heart
the motion picture production code is a
strong protection against self-appointed
wildcat censorship groups for his
conscientious open-minded and dignified
management of a difficult office the
Academy's Board has voted an honorary
award to the administrator of the code
mr. Joseph Breen
last year a major motion picture company
made a daring decision they took the
gamble of the decade with a picture
already in production they stopped cold
and switched to a revolutionary process
a process which proved a shot in the arm
to the whole industry in recognition of
their imagination showmanship and
foresight an honorary ward has been a
vote has been voted to the 20th Century
Fox Film corporation for introducing
cinema skull
it is being accepted by a man who is no
stranger to Academy Awards mr. Darryl
zanuck thank you very much
I should like to accept this on behalf
of mr. Spiro Skouras and mr. Alec Minh
and all the many thousands of employees
at 20th Century Fox who had a part in
not only making but merchandising
CinemaScope and I should also and I
don't think that I should be immodest to
accept it this award for CinemaScope on
behalf of millions of theater goers
throughout the world thank you
here to present the awards for
scientific or technical achievement is a
handsome swashbuckler who is checked his
sword and doublet at the moat mr.
Tyronne power
these scientific and technical awards
are divided into three classes this year
there are two class one awards for
designing and developing the multiple
photographic and projection systems
which culminated in Cinerama
we present a class one award to mr. Fred
Waller
in the absence of Fred Waller dr. Harry
case will accept the award mr. Waller
was ill and asked me to accept it a
class 1 award to Professor Ari Creighton
and Earl spa Nobel saw Halperin Lauren
green young Herbert Bragg and Karl
Faulkner of 20th Century Fox Studios for
creating developing and engineering the
processes and techniques known as
CinemaScope
if you saw Halperin will accept the
award song on behalf or those you have
honor here tonight I wish to thank you
we'd also like to thank mr. zanuck and
mr. scores for their inspiration and
their fortitude and all of those that
helped us put over this wonderful new
medium cinema scope and now a class to
award the Academy's plaque for the
development of a process of applying
strips of magnetic oxide to motion
picture film for sound recording and
reproduction we go to New York where Mr
hazard Reeves will accept the award for
the Reeves sound craft corporation
over half of reed soundwave corporation
i want to express our appreciation for
this honor
a class three award is voted to the
westrex corporation for the design and
construction of a new film editing
machine
these men honored tonight are a platoon
and the vast army of scientists and
technicians whose patience and unique
talents had helped to brighten the
screens of the world the Academy thanks
them all
the Faubourg award is given at the
discretion of the Board of Governors
when awarded it goes to the individual
responsible for the most consistent high
quality of motion picture production for
the current and two preceding years to
present it one of the very great
producers himself a Fahlberg winner mr.
David old Selznick
Irving Thalberg integrity required that
no motion picture be made without
benefit of all the time and all the
patience necessary to ultimate quality
and the finest talent in every
department
eminently qualified therefore to receive
the Thalberg award is that picture
makers picture maker a former cameraman
the sensitive and gifted producer and
director of a place in the Sun and chain
George Stevens
thank you so very much it certainly is a
double-barreled honor to receive the
Irving Thalberg award from the hands of
David Selznick I can't help but recall
as I stand here with this in my hand all
of the men that have had this honor
previous years and I am deeply regardful
of the significance and tradition of
this award I must think of course of all
of the people the writers and the actors
the cameramen and all of our associates
that put these pictures together make
them what they are and accept this award
for all of us thank you
well ladies gentlemen you know you may
wonder why mr. hole didn't make a speech
when he came up here we have naturally
before you television and consequently
were working on time I think if you had
seen what I had what I had seen is I
reached for his hand right over there
I don't think the man could have spoken
anyway he was just that true but anyway
now to get back through the scoop our
motion picture
any motion picture is never the work of
an individual the minds art skills and
the arts of many people must be united
in an effort to earn for any single
person only one picture the most coveted
award of our industry the an Oscar well
tonight we have honored some of the
people and some of the pictures chosen
by film workers but all of us are
indebted to you their audience who have
honored all of our products but your
patronage and enthusiasm we promise to
continue working toward perfection
exhilarated by the imposing list of
movies that will be made during the
coming years a greater array of stories
and stars and the screen has ever
boasted next March we will celebrate a
year of magnificent achievement and we
hope you will want to celebrate it with
us good night ladies and gentlemen and
thank you